like
this is the biggest deal ever like uh
danny jumped over
the great wall of china right like no
like the the
the relations between america and china
have never been really that great you
know it was a big deal to get permission
from china to go over there and jump a
skateboard over the wall what year
uh 2005 yeah yeah i think it was five
yeah yeah and so he goes over there on
the [ __ ] practice run
you broke your ankle or your foot that
was my ankle
yeah so he broke his [ __ ] ankle like
doing a practice run the day before
day before a day of day before
like the i wasn't supposed to take any
practice run but i could smell like i'm
like dude
they didn't they didn't they didn't
translate the
the dimensions correctly from metric to
or from standard to metric
language barrier some things came out
wrong on the ramp and i was like
visually like
whoa i can already tell like some shit's
not gonna feel exactly how
it normally does so i was adamant about
taking a test run before
you know the day before the government
was like you better not
like it's forbidden because somebody's
gonna get a photo or a video and i was
like
i'm gonna [ __ ] die if this in front
of everybody i'm [ __ ] figured out
right now
right so i took the test run right
before dark and
just like i thought there wasn't enough
roll in
right i came up short and landed on the
deck right
was another flaw because most of the
decks on these landing ramps
i always build them half the angle from
like 45
to vertical like i find like right yeah
they put a flat deck with a sharp edge
on it
normally i build like a roller over the
edge so if i did come up short
i could at least like get a little
forgiveness going in dude it was like a
square edge like this and i was like a
foot short dude a foot
like i could see the edge and i'm like
do i go head first and try and swan
or do i take it and i was like dude if i
come up short this way
i'm gonna die and this is all happening
in real time like
milliseconds of thoughts like okay which
way do i roll with this
and so instinctually i put my feet out
first and i landed on that edge of that
deck and cartwheeled down the thing and
fractured my ankle the night before the
next day
with the [ __ ] broken ankle he comes
back
and jumps over the [ __ ] great wall of
china
like and not and then and then that
wasn't even good enough he goes back up
and does a backside
360 air over the great wall of china i
did five 360s in a row
if i didn't break my ankle i would have
sessioned that i was like my goal was
like
to get like a film a segment like get a
bunch of tricks on video over the great
wall and make it its own thing
that was my fantasy i didn't realize i
was gonna break my ankle yeah
and and so at the end of the day there
there are how many people
have their name in gold on the great
wall of china
like five yes i'm like that
i'm the only american though yeah who's
the first five people in the world
i don't know dude like i don't know who
they are [ __ ] genghis khan
yeah it's a funny one i should do a
little research on that but i never
really
yeah i mean danny's not a big like self
patter on the backer yeah jesus dude
yeah dude